so there's a mixed reception from some
people that Lewis respected deeply
friends about the Narnia books what
what's that about yeah he read the first
few chapters of the first book The Lion
the Witch and the Wardrobe to his friend
tolken and tolken didn't much like what
he was hearing tolken thought the books
had been thrown together a bit
haphazardly uh if you know tolk's Middle
Earth that's a very different kind of
imagined space it's very rigorous and
thoroughgoing and it has what he called
the inner consistency of
reality n by contrast looks a little bit
slap Dash things Drawn Together from all
sorts of different mythological literary
Traditions the classics and fairy tale
and ebit sort of Edwardian stories and
Father Christmas is in there and tolkin
didn't like it and because tolkin has
become famous
uh his attitude to n has become famous
and lots of people have sort of followed
in tolk's wake and thought that tolken
knew the series much better than he
actually did and so they've sort of
jumped on the bandwagon and thought Oh
yeah n is not very good is it it's just
thrown together in an afternoon and um
it shouldn't be taken very seriously but
I think that's entirely wrong yeah
uh
why well because Lewis was not a random
or a slap Dash writer or thinker you
know had one of the most disciplined and
trained and controlled intellects of the
20th century he didn't do anything uh
casually or
thoughtlessly
um so n that argument won't quite do
though because tol Keen knew Lewis as a
friend for decades and so the fact that
Lewis was or was not like that does not
prove about this book true I'm leading
you to the assertion that that you have
proved about the
[Laughter]
book yeah well as I say tolkin dismissed
the books quite quickly you know he only
read or had read to him the first few
chapters of the first book and he you
know threw up his hands in horror and
turned away and he was a hard man to
please toling he disliked nearly
everything that Lewis wrote actually um
whereas Lewis in contrast loved the Lord
of the Rings and badgered tolken
endlessly to finish it um so it was a
LoveHate relationship they had Lewis
loved tolking works tolkin hated Lewis's
work that's an odd basis for a
friendship isn't it well they they were
in some ways chalk and cheese um but you
know Opposites
Attract anyway the the N books are are
not casually thrown together they are
they are structured I believe this is
the Discovery I made when I was doing my
doctoral research on Lewis's imagination
they're structured according to the
seven heavens the seven planets of
medieval cosmology which Lewis as a
medieval scholar knew all about and
which he described as spiritual symbols
of permanent value which were especially
worthwhile in his own
generation and it's those seven Heavens
from which we get the names of the days
of the week so the Sun the Moon Mars
Mercury Jupiter Venus and Saturn these
seven planets with their seven sets of
attributes and qualities and
influences that's what provided Lewis
with his scheme his blueprint his his
imaginative design now we're going to
explore that at length but before we do
you make an amazing statement uh which
apparently is true in your book uh Lewis
hid that
fact why would he do
that well he wrote a lot about the
planets in other works he wrote about
them academically in his book the
disgarded image you know tracing them
historically through literature and art
he wrote about them very explicitly in
his Trilogy of planetary Adventures
sometimes called the space trilogy but
that's a mistake it's better to call it
the ransom Trilogy and you know there
the seven Heavens are are used very
obviously you wrote about them too in
his
poetry but he thought that the best way
to understand the planets their
qualities the attributes their
personalities was was not through
laboriously listing all their all their
particular uh qualities but by seizing
them in an
intuition like you might smell a rose or
taste a wine and immediately recognize
it that's the best way of knowing it
these planetary personalities and so in
n he doesn't tell us what he's up to and
if he had disclosed the secret it would
have you frustrated the very thing he
was trying to achieve so that's why it
was underand as it were under the it
would have been a perfect answer to
Tolen
right yeah but then I
think Lewis didn't really much care the
what tolken thought if you know that OD
cuz you know there you go again TOS
would be the sort of response I think
and in any case you know an artist who
has to explain his art in order for it
to you know be uh judged worthy um has
failed so I don't think Lewis would have
felt under any uh he wouldn't have felt
incumbent upon him to explain himself
you know if it's not if it's not tolk's
pigeon it's not tolken
pigeon